SWORN ENEMY OF LYING, POMPOSITY,
SMUGNESS AND GROUPTHINK.
THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, "HANNITY."
NBC FAKE NEWS DID THEIR BEST TO
AMBUSH PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
TONIGHT’S TOWN HALL.
HE PRETTY MUCH DEBATED SAVANNAH
GUTHRIE AND WHAT WE ALL
WITNESSED WAS NOT JOURNALISM, IT
WAS A POLITICAL DEBATE WITH THE
MORNING HOST OF "THE TODAY SHOW"
SERVING AS JOE BIDEN SURROGATE
AND IT DIDN’T REALLY WORK OUT
WELL FOR HER.
QUESTIONS, TOPICS, TACTICS ALL
REEKING OF NOTHING BUT PURE,
POLITICAL BIAS.
OF COURSE, IN THE FIRST FEW
MINUTES, THE PRESIDENT WAS ONCE
AGAIN ASKED FOR THE
400 MILLIONTH TIME TO REPEAT
WHAT HE HAS SAID OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, TO CONDEMN WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> YOU ARE ASKED POINT BLANK TO
DENOUNCE WHITE SUPREMACY.
IN THE MOMENT, YOU DIDN’T.
YOU ASKED SOME FOLLOW-UP
QUESTIONS.
A COUPLE OF DAYS LATER ON A
DIFFERENT SHOW, YOU DENOUNCED
WHITE SUPREMACY.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS --
>> YOU’VE DONE THIS --
>> MY QUESTION IS --
>> I DENOUNCED WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> YOU DID TWO DAYS LATER.
>> I’VE DENOUNCED IT FOR YEARS.
YOU DIDN’T ASK JOE BIDEN WHETHER
HE DENOUNCES ANTIFA.
I WATCHED THE SHOW WITH LESTER
HOLT AND HE WAS ASKING QUESTIONS
LIKE BIDEN WAS A CHILD --
>> THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DODGE.
>> WAIT, ARE YOU LISTENING?
WHAT IS YOUR NEXT QUESTION?
>> IT FEELS AS IF YOU’RE
HESITANT TO DO SO.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN.
EVERY TIME -- IN FACT, THE
PEOPLE CAN COME I’M SURE THEY
WILL ASK YOU THE WHITE SUPREMACY
QUESTION.
I DENOUNCED WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> OKAY.
>> Sean: YOU NEED TO GET OUT
OF THE NEW YORK, LIBERAL,
ELITIST, OUT OF TOUCH BUBBLE
YOU’RE LIVING IN AND MAY BE READ
SOME OTHER NEWS OR TAKE A STEP
OUTSIDE THE FAR LEFT ENCLAVE
THAT IS CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC DNC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CONDEMNED,
SAVANNAH, WHITE SUPREMACY OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND IF YOU DIDN’T KNOW, YOU
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EVER HEARD THIS PRESIDENT SAY
ONE NEGATIVE THING ABOUT WHITE
SUPREMACIST?
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD IT?
>> I TOTALLY DISAVOW THE
KU KLUX KLAN.
I TOTALLY DISAVOW DAVID DUKE.
>> I GOT BACK IN THIS RACE
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF THE WOODS
CARRYING TORCHES, THEIR VEINS
BULGING.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND REMEMBER
WHAT YOU SAW.
AND A YOUNG WOMAN GETS KILLED
RESISTING HATE AND VIOLENCE IN
THE PRESIDENT GETS ASKED TO
COMMENT ON IT, WHAT DOES HE SAY?
HE SAYS THERE ARE VERY FINE
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
>> YOU HAD SOME VERY BAD PEOPLE
IN THAT GROUP, BUT YOU ALSO HAD
PEOPLE THAT WERE VERY FINE
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
AND I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
NEO-NAZIS IN THE WHITE
NATIONALISTS, BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD BE CONDEMNED TOTALLY.
>> DAVID DUKE, FOR GOD SAKE.
>> I REJECT DAVID DUKE, I’VE
REJECTED THE KKK, THE
KU KLUX KLAN.
FROM THE TIME I WAS FIVE YEARS
OLD, I REJECTED THEM.
>> Sean: AT THIS POINT THE
ABUSIVELY BIASED MSNBC LYING
ONCE AGAIN TO SMEAR THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT FACTS,
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT RESEARCH,
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT TRUTH,
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT
FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS, ESPECIALLY
NOT MSDNC NEWS, WHICH IS
COMPLETELY CORRUPT, AS WE SAW
TONIGHT.
IT IS A CONSPIRATORIAL WING OF
THE DNC AND BASICALLY NOTHING
BUT STATE RUN TELEVISION.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
ELECT SLEEPY JOE BIDEN AND
GUTHRIE’S OWN HUSBAND WAS
AL GORE’S TRAVELING CHIEF OF
STAFF.
WHAT A SHOCK.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THIS EVENT,
WHICH WAS BILLED AS A TOWN HALL
WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A
CONTENTIOUS POLITICAL DEBATE
WITH GUTHRIE INTERRUPTING THE
PRESIDENT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN, ALL IN THE NAME OF
FAIRNESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT FELT REALLY GOOD AND --
>> DID THE DOCTORS EVER TELL YOU
THAT IT’S ON THE MONEY ON YOUR
LONG >> NO BUT THEY SAID THE
LUNGS ARE LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT,
PERHAPS INFECTED --
>> INFECTED WITH?
>> I DON’T KNOW, I TESTED
POSITIVE.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT TESTING
BECAUSE THERE’S A LITTLE
CONFUSION WITH THIS.
DID YOU TEST THE DAY OF THE
DEBATE?
>> YOU CAN’T LET THIS CONTINUE
TO GO ON WITH THE LOCKDOWN’S.
CITIES THAT ARE RUN BY DEMOCRATS
WHO DON’T --
>> WHILE WE ARE OUT ON THE
TOPIC, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
QANON.
>> I DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
HE WENT ON.
>> I JUST TOLD YOU.
>> Sean: I KNOW NOTHING BY Q
AND ON AND BY THE WAY, I HAVE NO